Good Morning Boys,
girls,
and interested others.
I said a couple of days ago,
last week that I was going to produce
three videos on political correctness
and that the third one would be about
tactics.
So that's what I'm doing this morning.
I'll probably produce a number of
relatively short videos on tactics
because I think that that might be more
effective way to,
to disseminate them.
And so by tactics,
what I'm trying to figure out is how the
rhetoric surrounding these issues can be
translated into effective action at the
individual level.
So I'm hoping that people who want to
play a tactical game with the,
with a PC extremists,
uh,
take it upon themselves as individuals
to stand up against this and to
hopefully do something about it.
And,
and that's not going to be an easy thing
to do.
And hopefully we can do it with some
good humor and,
and some and some and a light touch and
a bit of detachment and in a peaceful
and thoughtful and rational way.
And so I'm going to propose a game today
that I've designed with some of the
people who are helping me think this
through.
And I'm gonna walk you through that.
All right.
So we're gonna start by talking about
the PC game and the PC game is a form of
videology.
And,
uh,
what an ideology does is attempt to
simplify the world in a very radical way
so that it indicates to it's holders
that they have understanding even when
they don't.
And that way it reduces uncertainty,
uncertainty,
and anxiety.
And it also helps them improve their
short term regulation because if they
can view themselves,
idiot logs can view themselves as proper
game players,
then they can feel good about their
position in the world.
And so the purpose of the PC game,
which I think is technically a biased
compression algorithm,
what it does is it takes the complexity
of the world and compresses it to a few
simple axioms.
Um,
and it does that.
It's a biased impression,
your algorithm,
I think because it doesn't accurately
represent the complexity of the world
across,
it's the full array of,
of detail necessary to deal with it
effectively.
Um,
all right,
so here are the rules of the PC game
and,
and this is I think what's taught to
students,
uh,
on mouse in universities now as an
alternative to actual critical thinking
and the development of a comprehensive
and powerful and a functional individual
philosophy.
It's the alternative to wisdom.
That's one way of looking at it.
Okay,
so here are the rules of the PC game.
First of all,
what you do is identify an area of human
activity.
Could be any error of human activity.
Uh,
could be sports,
it could be writing,
it could be socioeconomic status,
it could be that the garnering of
wealth.
It doesn't matter anywhere where people
are doing something that can be
identifiably,
um,
measured in terms of its outcome and
evaluate along that way.
Then the next thing you do is you note
that there's a distribution of success.
And of course there's a distribution of
success in any human creative activity.
And it's partly because in most human
domains of activity,
there are winner take all games.
That's called a pareto distribution.
You can look that up if you want.
but most domains of human creative
achievement,
followup prieto distribution.
And that's why,
for example,
that a very small minority of people
have most of the money.
Um,
it's also true that a small minority of
authors write most of the books and a
small minority of those who sell books
have,
uh,
the biggest bestsellers and why a very
small number of recordings,
for example,
audio recordings become successful.
And why a very small number of players
dominate each game.
And it's very common.
So there's definitely a distribution of
success in any domain of human activity.
So you note that then what you do is
identify the people who are being
successful as winners and the people who
are being relatively unsuccessful as
losers.
Okay.
And then you claim that the losers are
losing only because they are oppressed
by the winters.
So you can dispense with things like
competence and quality when you're doing
that.
And that's really useful if you're an
enemy of competence and quality.
So anyways,
you claim that the losers are losing
because they're oppressed by the
winners.
Then you claiming allegiance with the
losers and so you put yourself on the
side of those that you define as
unfairly victimized.
Then that allows you to do two things.
One is to feel secure in your
comprehensive explanation of the world.
And it also helps if you surround
yourself with people who think exactly
the same way you do,
because then that oversimplified and
actually rather pathetic comprehensive
explanation of the world never goes on
challenged.
Then the next thing you do is revel in
your moral superiority because what
you've done as well as oversimplifying
the world is placed yourself forever on
the side of the morally righteous.
And you've been able to do that with a
minimum of cognitive effort and no ass,
no actual expertise and no real desire
to mate or no,
no commitment to making a positive
change in the world.
Because that's a very,
very difficult thing.
It takes years to make a positive
change.
Even at,
at,
uh,
kind of a minute level of the social
structure.
So,
so you've oversimplified the world,
you get to revel in your moral
superiority and this is the real dark
side of such movements is that whatever
resentment you might have as a
consequence of construing yourself as a
victim or as identify or because of
identifying with victims that's
generated a fair bit of resentment would
you can then target towards your newly
discovered enemies and resentment fueled
targeting is a very dangerous
phenomenon.
Um,
it's the sort of thing that,
well,
suffice it to say that it's a very
dangerous phenomenon,
then what you do is repeat the game
forever everywhere.
And it's,
it's a very good game in that regard
because you can continually identify new
domains of human achievement and you can
continually multiply the categories of,
of winners and losers and you can do
that outed and fund item essentially.
So that it's a game that you can never,
it's a game that will never end,
which is part of the reason why I'm
doing what I can to try to put a stop to
it,
or at least put a stop to its perceived
validity.
It's really,
look,
I mean,
you can learn to play this game in about
two hours and that's what people are
taught to do in many,
many university,
uh,
departments now.
And I think it's,
I think it's absolutely pathetic.
I think it's morally reprehensible.
I think it's,
uh,
it,
it abandons the principle of individual
responsibility.
I think it's intellectually specious.
I think it's hollow.
I think it's badly motivated.
Uh,
there's almost no end to the number of
bad things that can be said about this
game.
Okay.
And,
and I think it's got out of hand,
so,
so why has it become necessary to do
something about this now?
Well,
I,
as I said already,
I think it's gone too far.
Of course,
that's only my own personal opinion,
but I'm trying to stay attentive to the
psychological underpinnings of the
political landscape.
And it is my opinion that this has gone
too far.
And,
um,
you know,
pc,
the PC movement was quite powerful in
the 1990s,
although it disappeared back into the
underworld from,
from which it emerged.
And I thought maybe at that point we
were done with it,
but that was wrong because it's come
back with a vengeance,
especially in the last five years.
And I've been trying to sort of why that
is and here's why what I think's
happening.
I think that the universities,
especially the radical left leaning
departments and those would be the
women's studies departments and,
and,
and those,
those sorts of places.
Um,
there's other departments that I think
are also primarily responsible.
Um,
there are estimates that about 20% of
social scientists identify themselves to
use a cursed phrase as Marxists.
And,
uh,
you know,
I don't think that's a very good idea
because Marxism produced the death of
millions of people in the 20th century.
And if you don't think that Marxism was
Marxism was directly responsible for
that,
then I would recommend that you read
Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn Gulag
archipelago.
Of course it's 2,700 pages long and it's
extraordinarily emotionally draining to
read.
But Solzhenitsyn does an unbelievably
good job of detailing out his argument
for why the murderous excesses of places
like this Delonis Soviet Union and Mao's
China and Vietnam and Cambodia and all
the other places where Marxist murders
took place,
weren't aberrations in relationship to
Marxist ideas,
but the purest expression of the,
of the philosophy that was embodied
inside that,
that doctrine.
So you can read that if you want.
It's one of the seminal books of the
20th century and I don't think that you,
you can actually have a reasonable
dialog about this sort of thing if
you're not familiar with it.
Partly because Solzhenitsyn's book was
one of the major causes of the collapse
of the Soviet Union.
Uh,
he,
he eradicated any shreds of intellectual
respectability that the doctrine upon
which the Soviet Union had been built,
still maintained after,
after it's decades of,
of unbelievable murderous existed.
So I'd recommend that you read that,
um,
before you enter into this kind of
argument.
But,
uh,
one of the things I'm going to do is to
start to make some videos about soldier
Mitson and his writing so that everybody
has a chance to understand what it was
that he was talking about because 2,700
pages is a pretty long slog.
So anyways,
there have been many,
many left radical left leaning
departments,
training people over the last 30 years.
I'm not only in how to think they've
taught them how to play the PC game,
but they explain,
explicitly trained them how to become
effective activists.
And if you go on women's studies
websites for example,
I've done this with many such websites,
they proudly trumpet their training of,
of radical leftist activists and they're
very,
very good at it.
Make no mistake.
And so I think the universities have
probably trained,
I don't know exactly how to generate the
estimates.
I think the lower bound is about 300,000
people and the upper bound might be 10
times that trained them over the last 30
years.
Um,
and now they exist at many levels of the
social hierarchy and you know,
so at the top level of the social
hierarchy,
there's our political structures and
then you can fragment that into major
organizations and fragment that into
minor sub organizations and put the
individuals at the bottom of that.
Um,
I think that the,
the PC,
the PC game players have infiltrated our
institutions at many,
many levels of the hierarchy.
Um,
and they're also now writing legislation
at the top.
And now we've got a positive feedback
loop going between the legislation,
legislative activities at the top and
the people who are acting as essentially
insurgents for this movement at all the
levels of the social hierarchy.
And it's producing an increasingly
rigidified positive feedback loop.
I think it's also,
you could also think about it as an
example of what has been described as
the long march through the institutions.
Uh,
you can look this up on Wikipedia,
the long march through the institutions,
but we'll look first to say what to see.
What Herbert marcuse said about it.
Uh,
marcuse was a member of the Frankfurt
School of critical theory,
which is a neo Marxist school of
thought.
Um,
he commented about this idea of the long
march through the institutions,
which was a,
a student named Rudy Dukie in the 1960s
generated this idea.
And here's the idea.
We have to work against the established
institutions while working within them,
but not simply by boring,
from within.
Rather by doing the job,
learning how to program and read
computers,
how to teach at all levels of education,
how to use the mass media,
how to organize production,
how to recognize an issue,
planned obsolescence,
how to design,
et Cetera.
And at the same time,
preserve our consciousness in working
with others.
And that means our political
consciousness.
So,
you know,
this has happened and it's happened at
least in part,
as a consequence of conscious planning.
And so,
um,
to me that,
to me,
that,
that seems a potentially very dangerous,
um,
because it doesn't take that many
committed people.
Uh,
it doesn't take that large of a large,
uh,
committed minority to produce
substantive changes in the society.
So,
and,
uh,
we see those changes happening now and I
think they're,
they're very detrimental to things as
free speech.
And I regard free speech as a
prerequisite to a civilized society
because freedom of speech means that you
can have combat with words.
That's what it means.
It doesn't mean that people can happily
and gently exchange opinions.
It means that we can engage in combat
with words and the battleground of ideas
and the reason that that's acceptable
and why it's acceptable that people's
feelings get hurt during that combat is
that the combat of ideas is far
preferable to actual combat.
And it's also the only alternative
because people have genuine
disagreements.
And if you don't let them talk them out
and reach some sort of consensus,
some court of negotiated settlement,
then then they can either swallow their
opinions and become enraged or they can
engage in actual combat.
And so I think anything that threatens
freedom of speech threatens the
stability of the society.
And I think the PC accesses,
uh,
threatened freedom of speech.
And I think they threatened it quite
severely.
I already know people,
for example,
at the universities who are loath to
teach anything to do with gender or
sexual identity because they're afraid
of saying the wrong thing.
And that puts a pall over,
over,
over free discussion at the university
on,
on a whole array of vital issues.
So,
all right,
so having said that,
I've identified the PC game,
I've identified why I think it's
dangerous and why it spread so rapidly.
Um,
I think that now we need at least in
part,
we need tactics to fight back.
And so one of the things I'm going to
propose as a counter game and here's the
principles that I think the counter game
has to be able to,
um,
here's the features that the counter
game has to have.
It has to play,
be playable everywhere.
Cause obviously the PC game is playable
everywhere.
It has to make the point.
And the point is that there is
widespread opposition to these pc ideas
and that the opposition is,
is uh,
is,
important and uh,
needs to be attended to carefully.
It has to spread fast and it would help
if it was a bit humorous because it
would be good if we could do this with a
bit of detachment and um,
some rationality and some careful
argumentation and some playfulness and,
and some,
um,
well all of that would be real good.
But it's not an easy thing to manage
because it's a serious business and um,
but you have to keep a light touch when
you're doing this sort of thing.
That's one of the indications that
you've actually attained some mastery
over it.
So keep that in mind when,
when you're,
if you're interested in this sort of
thing.
So I'm going to announce pokemon pc and
I'd like to first say that of course the
good people who've produced the pokemon
artifacts in the past and products have
nothing to do with this.
And so,
um,
they can't be blamed for it and I hope
they'll forgive me for using their
terminology in a satirical and political
manner.
It can,
everyone can play.
It's all the rage.
It's spreading like wildfire.
Here are the rules to Pokemon PC.
First purchase your starter pack of
Pokemon pc stickers.
So I've put them on Ebay.
I've ordered about 5,000 of them.
You can buy a starter pack of 50 or a
hundred.
Um,
and if you feel like doing that,
then I would encourage you to do it.
I don't know if people will be
interested in this,
but it's an experiment considered an
experiment.
If you're feeling really enthusiastic by
a couple of them,
give them to your friends.
Advanced players can purchase the
accessory packs too,
and the accessory packs or larger
stickers at least to begin with.
And I'll post them relatively quickly.
So here's the sticker.
So here's the design principles.
Uh,
we didn't want it to be black,
red and white,
like the antismoking stickers,
you know,
because that just seemed a bit much.
So we decided to make it look kind of
peaceful and playful and you know,
it's,
it's green and purple and,
um,
it's not an,
it's not in an,
in your face sort of thing.
And this doesn't have to be an in your
face sort of thing.
And so I liked the design and some of
the people who are advising and helping
me.
I've been working on that.
So that's what the PC stickers look
like.
There are two inches by two inches and
we've designed them well.
I'll continue with the rules of the
Pokemon pc game.
Okay,
so there's just starter packs there.
Ebay item one,
two,
(216) 702-3413 all of course post that
on the,
on this youtube website there's a
Snipley,
uh,
like it's like a bitly,
you a url for,
for that particular item.
The hundred sticker item is one,
two,
(216) 700-1902.
So you can buy 50 sticker packs or a
hundred sticker packs and then you can
start using them to play pc pokemon.
And here are the rules.
First,
take your starter pack of 50 to 100
stickers to school or work.
It can be carried conveniently in a
backpack or a briefcase or under your
shirt.
If you're a real double o seven type,
then wander the halls of your
institution or workplace,
be stealth,
healthful.
And if you need to whistle nonchalantly
so that people don't know what you're up
to,
you lose points if you get caught too
early in the game.
Pay careful attention while you're doing
this.
And I would say always pay careful
attention.
So this is the eye of horus,
by the way.
It's an old Egyptian God and the
Egyptians worshiped at 10 attention as
their highest daddy.
They regarded the careful attention that
individuals paid as the antidote to the
corruption in stagnation of the state.
So horace was an open eyed God who
rescued his father from the underworld.
And so he's the god of attention.
And I guess I could think about him as
the patron saint of the PC pokemon
movement.
Okay,
then now you're in your institution or
your workplace or your school and you're
wandering around and you're looking for
posters that advertise the PC game.
Now to describe what the PC game is so
you can use your judgment about what
posters are designed to support that
game.
And I would say do it carefully.
You know,
think about it.
And don't just put the stickers
everywhere because that reduces their
utility.
Look at a poster.
Think if you think,
think and considered to see if it is
playing the game that I described it.
And if it is,
then stealthily remove one of your
Pokemon pc stickers from your starter
pack.
Remove the backing.
If you need eye protection while you're
doing that because you're concerned
about the danger,
make sure that you wear it,
handled the sticker reverently then
strike like the Cobra.
That's the sticker Cobra by the way.
Um,
and I found this guy on the right here,
Mano Mano is a Canadian Hero Mono the
Air Cobra.
So I guess he could be another,
he's our patron superhero,
I guess.
Mono the Air Cobra.
So you strike like mono the Air Cobra.
Canadian superheroes by the way,
are pretty rare.
So,
uh,
it's hard.
All right,
so take your pokemon pc sticker and
carefully place it on the lower right
side of the poster.
I've put an example down here.
You can see there's an example of proper
placement,
um,
right there.
Put the PC sticker on the lower right
part of the PC game poster.
Be a little subtle.
Okay.
Don't stick it.
Obviously in bone headedly in the
middle,
you want to let the PC game poster
continue to broadcast it's evil message,
but you want to register your opposition
and more importantly you want to show
that someone's paying attention,
okay?
Because we need to show that people are
paying attention to this sort of things.
I don't think that people who are
playing these games are particularly
brave and so I think if proper attention
is called to what they're doing,
they might wander back into the darkness
that initially spawned them.
All right.
The next thing you do,
I would like you to do is photograph.
Use your cell phone to photograph the
newly modified poster and then I want
you to prepare to upload that photo when
what I hope will be the pokemon pc app
arrives and later in the video I'm going
to call for an app designer because I
would like volunteers to help me design
an APP that has a certain number of
features and more features.
If you have ideas for more features,
it's welcome.
So I would ask the APP producers to send
me a proposal.
Uh,
you could either do it as volunteers or
you could send me a budget and I'll see
if I can scrounge up the money to pay
for it.
I can certainly use the whatever revenue
might be generated with the PC,
pokemon pc stickers to generate enough
revenue maybe to develop the APP.
So there's an example of proper
placement.
Be Nice and careful.
Stick it on the lower right hand,
right hand side.
Um,
if,
if more than one of you come across the
same poster,
I suppose you could put another sticker
on there beside it that would register a
vote,
but another vote say,
uh,
against the,
the content of that poster.
But don't use a bunch of stickers from
your starter packs on the same poster,
right?
So be subtle and,
and,
and intelligent about all this and
careful and awake and tough and,
and,
uh,
all of the things that you should be if
you're a good,
well functioning individual.
All right.
And then you disappear stealthily into
the night.
Like Zorro.
I guess,
or maybe someone else so you can pick
your stealthily,
disappear or,
and emulate them.
And it's good thing to emulate people
that you admire.
And so pick somebody you admire and
emulate that sucker and that'd be a good
idea.
So then,
then 10 play again with another poster.
Yeah.
And again,
and then again and then again and then
again as long as necessary for years if
necessary.
All right.
Because this,
this is a long haul.
Uh,
this is a long haul process and this is
only the starting place as far as I can
tell.
So I'm going to call for an APP designer
for all you people out there who have
computer ability.
I,
I'd like you to design a pokemon pc app
that can be used as a mobile
application.
I would like it to be able to upload
photos of Pokemon pc stickered posters
and then I want it to link to Google
maps.
I don't know how that might be done.
And what I would like to have happen is
that we can get a comprehensive library
of pc posters.
So that's why I want you to be very
careful in what you select to sticker.
And that we could also make a map a now
of the,
of the distribution of these posters,
because then we can find out where the
layers of the PC game players are.
And then we can go on to the next
version of Pokemon PC,
which I have to think through and which
we'll announce later.
And so I would say thanks for playing
kids and always remember play Pokemon pc
safely
over and out.